I'm gonna be a pilot best in the galaxy
that chronicles harm learning that it is
better to shoot first and second the
very beginning it is an adventure like
yeah kick-off the beginning and just
like ah and you're on that kind of crazy
journey with everyone I think you get to
see this character come together there
are some really juicy bits in it that I
think will make proper fans really happy
and I think that people who don't know
anything about this but my mum she'll
get it
I'm a driver and I'm a squire this is an
ideal sort of IMAX dramatic experience
it's an immersive movie it's exciting
and I think that there's very little
else like that IMAX theatrical
experience and here's a movie that's
very much made with that in mind that
would be great to see so good in the
cockpit of the Millennium Falcon there
was a IMAX in front of us like the
screen where we flew it through and it
was like the best cuz like it just
you're surrounded by space
they'll just get like chewy in the face
chewy face that was my moment that's it
it's like you're inside of this world
you're so into the story and you're so
into all these kind of so much is
happening it's like a real spectacular
now we're in trouble there for a second
but it's fun we're fine